aujourd'hui encore l'urgence de charles
lemoyne est rempli après cinq heures
d'attentes claudette loisel quitte la
salle sans que son fils marc qui n'a été
traitée pour une plaie qui s'est
infectée
5 pillay et deux heures
elle est ici parce que son fils n'a plus
de médecin de famille et puis de
médecins savent pour catane 1
les médecins ils sont toujours à son
ancien médecin qui a pris sa retraite
c'est une des principales sources de
l'engorgement des urgences qui
s'accentue depuis quatre ans la durée
moyenne de séjour ambulatoire a
légèrement augmenté passant de 4 heures
10 minutes à 4 heures 28 minutes entre
2018 et 2022 mais pour les patients sur
civière la dégradation est plus marquée
en 2018 la durée moyenne de séjour était
de 13 heures 42 minutes au début de la
pandémie latentes sur civière à monter à
15h15 et en ce printemps 2022 elle
atteint
16h45 le gouvernement nous sert
l'exemple excuses de la pandémie
aujourd'hui pour justifier et temps
d'attenté aux urgences le gouvernement
cherche des solutions à ce problème
chronique la moitié des personnes qui
vont à l'urgence devrait pas est à
l'urgence du reggae de vue leur première
ligne dans une clinique privée ou un
clsc
mais pour les patients sur civière c'est
souvent le manque d'hébergement ou de
l'eee ailleurs dans l'hôpital qui les
immobilise à l'urgente
encore plus rapidement quand les
patients arrivent quand il en faudrait
attendre
cette pression
les urgences pour les gens comme
claudette et son fils mark on ne voit
pas vraiment de solution à court terme
belge frustré je suis frustré peu
importe les solutions mises de l'avant
pour tenter de décongestionner les
urgences il faudra tout d'abord en
arriver à régler le problème de pénurie
de main d'oeuvre qui frappe tous les
maillons du réseau de la santé ici david
gentilles et radio-canada longueur